We are live, Kate, what are you doing?
Just seeing when the next iPhone is coming
out.
The next?
Well, yeah, I missed the last one, and so
I figured I'd just jump onto the 15.
You've seen the old brick I've got here.
Maybe that's a good idea, because the next
one might not be made in China.
I mean, it might not be made in India, but
it could be assembled in India.
Why is that?
That's because, you know, COVID and they were
lockdowns and the whole supply chain suffered.
That's true.
And now we saw over Christmas, the production
was limited.
And so, it seems like China is missing out
and other countries can't really wait so long.
So maybe they're going to look to diversify.
Yeah.
And that diversifying might be good for India.
Which means jobs, possibly.
That is right.
So, the question we're going to ask today
is: I s diversifying from China creating jobs
in India?
All right.
Welcome to Global Eyes, where we take a deep
dive into the security policy issues affecting
your lives and our lives.
I'm Isha.
And I'm Kate.
So, today we're going to talk about chips
and wafers.
Excuse me?
Not the snacks - chips and wafers, but the
semiconductor chips.
They are everywhere like these tiny things,
they are in our smartphones, they are in laptops,
washing machines, cars…
Toothbrushes!
Toothbrushes, imagine they're everywhere.
And you just can't imagine a world without
them today.
So the thing is that they have become an integral
part of the functioning of any society today.
And mainland China is the fastest growing
chip producer in the world.
And Taiwan is home to the most important chip
factory in the world.
And it's called Taiwan Semiconductor Manufacturing
Company, or TSMC for short.
I prefer the shortened version of TSMC.
Right.
So now, if for any reason China decides to
stop the production or if the production stops
like it happened in COVID, now the whole globe
is going to be affected by that.
And that's the big deal.
We've seen that during the pandemic: In Germany,
I know a lot of people who are not able to
buy cars now.
These huge chunks of steel, they're actually
there, but you can't use them.
They're useless because those semiconductor
chips, they're not there.
They were not coming from China.
So that's the thing.
If people don't diversify, the world would
come to a standstill.
Exactly.
And I think now we can go to our first guest
and understand things in a better manner.
I just wanted to give a little briefing so
that we know what we're really talking about.
But I guess our first guest can actually make
us understand it better.
So let's find out exactly what that means
and especially for India.
So let's bring in our first guest.
With us now we have Mr. Arjun Gargeyas, who's
currently based in Delhi.
He is an expert at high tech geopolitics and
a consultant for the Indian Ministry of Electronics
and Information Technology.
Thank you so much for joining us on Global
Eyes.
Hello, nice to meet you.
And nice to be here.
Now, Arjun has written this wonderful paper
on silicon diplomacy, and I can highly recommend
it.
I must say, Kate and I, we really enjoyed
reading it.
We learnt a lot of things and we also got
confused about a lot of things.
And so let's start talking about the paper
first.
So Arjun, there are a lot of nitty gritties,
like you've started the paper with that: semiconductors,
transistors, chips.
Now these are terms that we use loosely; I
don't think everybody realizes while talking
about it, what they're actually talking about.
So if you could just explain that first of
all, so that we can put this in perspective
that what exactly is happening in China?
What is happening in Taiwan?
And where does India fit into this whole picture?
Sure, sure.
I mean, to give you a primer, right?
I think people started talking about semiconductors
and chips, especially during the COVID 19
pandemic when there was a global shortage.
But clearly, the definition of a chip, of
semiconductor material and all kind of got
mixed up.
And that is where, you know, the policy perspective
for any person kind of got muddled.
Just to put things in perspective, a semiconductor
is just another material.
It is from the silicon family that can be
silicon germanium, silicon carbide, then gallium
nitride.
These are materials which are basically in
between conductors and insulators, and they
are used as substrate or just like wafers
in chips.
Chips are what we use in all our regular electronic
products: laptops, mobile phones, anything,
iPod, basically anything which we use that
has a chip in it.
Now having said that, what a semiconductor
is, what a chip is and what a transistor is,
what is being produced in China, what is being
produced in Taiwan, and where does India come
in?
Okay.
So if you talk about the production of a chip
itself, it undergoes multiple handovers in
terms of the raw material, which is the semiconductor
material has different place....
Basically different places have different
deposits of raw materials, like China has
a high deposit of silicon and even the US.
So that is basically the starting point of
it.
That's the raw material, right?
And then you design the s and then you manufacture
the chip.
So let's go by the four basic phases of how
you manufacture the chip itself or how you
make the product.
One is the raw materials, which is the semiconductor
materials.
Then is the design phase wherein you have
engineers kind of using software to place
these kinds of transistors and on the chip
itself and kind of design it in a way that
they can communicate with each other.
And then comes the manufacturing or the fabrication.
But this is where you kind of use high precision
materials, high precision equipment.
Taiwan is the powerhouse in the manufacturing
phase.
So in the manufacturing phase, they are the
powerhouse in the world.
So they manufacture over 60% of the world's
total chips.
And this is because they run on what we call
as the pure play foundry model.
So what that is basically is that the fact
that Taiwanese firms, they are not into any
of the other aspects of the supply chain,
they just do the manufacturing bit.
So they take in designs from American firms,
some South Korean firms, some Japanese firms,
some Chinese firms.
And then they take the designs and then they
manufacture it and give back the product to
them.
So that is all they do.
Now, China is trying to do all aspects, right.
So they believe in being self-sufficient across
the supply chain.
But it is hard, as we know, that each phase
has different kind of requirements, different
kind of expertise required.
So it's just the fact that China has been
trying to do it and has kind of made some
kind of gains.
But where they are most concentrated right
now is in the assembly, test and packaging
aspect.
So they do the large part of it after the
chip is manufactured.
You see big Chinese factories assembling products,
putting these chips into certain electronic
products.
Apple has one of their biggest assembly-like
factories in China.
So China has been doing that itself.
And they're also trying to get into the manufacturing
bit, because they clearly know that the world
is heavily dependent on Taiwan, and they have
kind of made their own manufacturing industry.
SMIC is their main contract manufacturer,
wherein they kind of manufacture these chips
for local domestic semiconductor firms.
So, I mean, that's the thing right now.
And when it comes to India right now and going
forward, what kind of role are we expect India
to play?
So India has been trying to build a fabrication
facility or a manufacturing facility from,
let's say, almost 40 years.
It's almost from the 1970s, 1980s.
They've been trying to do it.
But so far till now, they have not been able
to build a commercial fabrication facility.
There are a few fabs or what we call manufacturing
centers in India.
But these are very, very specific and they
cater only to the defense industry, the space
industry, which is basically the government
owned sector.
There is no commercial fab that is operating
in the country and they've been trying to
do it.
But their current strength actually lies in
the design aspect.
So you see that Indian engineers are at the
forefront of designing these chips.
These are electronics engineers, myself being
one.
And I worked in a semiconductor firm before
actually transitioning into policy.
So I know for a fact that almost all of the
design from major American firms like US-firms
like Intel, Qualcomm, NVIDIA, AMD, everything
like even from Taiwanese firms, even from
South Korean firms such as Samsung, so all
these designs are done by Indian engineers
who are sitting in the country.
So most of these semiconductor firms have
their design centers in India, and that is
being done by Indian engineers.
So would you say - looking ahead to the future,
that there's actually more potential in the
design side of things than the manufacturing
when it comes to India's role?
Because if you think of just you were mentioning
about how China is trying to push to be self-sufficient
across the supply chain.
Surely it would take such a long time to build
up that kind of expertise that China has in
producing models.
You know, could India even go down that route
in the long term?
Again: So semiconductor self-sufficiency is
such an ambitious task.
Like no one has been able to achieve that.
Not even the biggest tech powers in the country,
not US, not Europe, not China, because each
aspect of the supply chain is so, so, so intricate
and fragile, because there are so many different
things which come into the picture.
And as you said, it has taken Taiwan almost
50 years to actually build that semiconductor
industry, which is the manufacturing bit.
And the TSMC and UMC, which are their biggest
firms, which are the contract manufacturers
for Taiwan, have been created and set up almost
since the 1960s.
And to reach where they have reached now,
it has taken significant amount of capital
investment, trade policy changes and it's
a huge - it's like a marathon.
It's not a sprint.
And India, again, having a fab in India is
always a good thing, because you can actually
manufacture for the domestic consumption itself.
That is definitely there.
But again, like what kind of fab it is because
the high end fab takes so much amount of investments
to actually set up.
So that is why design itself is a low hanging
fruit for India, because they already have
the talent in the country.
They just do not have the semiconductor firms.
Most of them work for American or basically
not Indian firms.
And so if India can actually nurture that
talent and kind of build domestic or domestic
sector, thriving sector of semiconductor design
firms, that means that India would kind of
basically be the contract designers.
Similarly, how Taiwan is a contract manufacturer,
all the firms can actually get their designs
done by Indian firms and then they can move
on to manufacturing the chip itself.
I have to say, I love the way you keep using
the word "fab".
I mean, I've used "fab" for something else.
For me, "fab" is fabulous, right?
But this is fabrication centre.
To put it into context and the way you've
been explaining about the chips, the semiconductors,
I think if there were a mascot for globalization,
it should be semiconductor chips, because
you can't have one country doing everything.
And you've talked about India having expertise
in design.
But if it is just design and if for one country
to have a production line, it takes such a
long time and so much of expertise.
Why was India chosen, if I may use the word
chosen, for the billion-dollar investment?
So I think it was in December 2021 that Indian,
the Indian government, the Ministry of Electronics
and IT came out with the semiconductor fab
ecosystem.
One of their major, major goals is to get
a fab in the country, because we do not have
any commercial fab right now and it is hurting
us majorly, because we were so totally dependent
on imports and our biggest imports are from
China itself.
And that is something that the government
wants to change.
In the semiconductor industry, even a billion
dollars is just peanuts.
It´s: You cannot set up a high-end fabrication
facility with a billion dollars.
Like you need immense amount of capital to
just set up a basic functioning unit of a
fab for, let's say, a 28-nanometer chip, which
is a mid-range.
So as you decrease the nanometers, the more
transistors are put onto the chip and the
more computing power is there.
So currently we are at five nanometers, three
nanometers, which is too expensive.
India cannot afford to put so much capital
into just one fabrication facility.
And very, very few players are actually involved
in kind of doing this.
There are not many players TSMC, Samsung,
Intel, these are the only major players in
the whole world who can actually do a five
nanometer or three nanometer fabrication facility
itself.
So India does not have that amount of capital
and they have not been able to actually attract
these big firms to set up any kind of fabrication
facility in the country.
From what you're saying about how much it
would actually cost to create the especially
these high-end chips, do you think it's very
or rather less likely then that we're really
going to see any of the really state of the
art high tech being produced in India in the
coming years?
And is that more likely to stay in Taiwan,
for example, for the time being?
Yes, definitely.
It's not going to come to India anytime soon,
and it's because it's concentrated with, like
very, very like just two or three firms across
the world.
And this technology also is not easily transferable,
because you can't just say that, oh, I'll
tell you how to do it, and you can do it because
there's so many other factors that come into
the picture.
So there is so many dependencies which have
been created.
And India cannot like, you know, plug holes
into all of them right now.
They kind of have to focus their resources
on their strengths, which is their comparative
advantages also in the in the value chain.
I'm actually quite intrigued to understand
how this is going to affect the job market,
because semiconductors is a huge business.
And even whatever level you're talking about,
if it's entering the Indian market, that is
probably going to take a big chunk of the
job market, isn't it?
I mean, are we going to see less rate of unemployment
because of this?
Do you have any idea how the government plans
are as far as employment is concerned?
So, I mean, that's the thing, right?
So in each part of the value chain, you kind
of you need different required skill sets
also.
So for especially manufacturing, you need
experienced labor.
You need kind of people who have the like
they're well, well-educated enough to understand
how to work manufacturing equipment, like
a fabrication equipment itself.
But for an assembly or testing or a packaging
part, you do not need that level of education
in your laborers itself.
It can be, they can be like, this is just
low-cost labor.
And that is why India can kind of get into
that rather than this.
And especially in design, it's very, very
technical.
Right.
So these are basically engineers who have
come out or just come out of college who are
looking to contribute to the semiconductor
industry and all the opportunities they have
now are either directly with the US or like
basically non-Indian firms or with services
firms.
There are a lot of semiconductor design services
firms in the country.
Then they take a project of the bigger players,
right?
So like Texas Instruments or Intel or something.
They say, we will take up your project and
we'll design it for you and they'll hire engineers
from colleges and the universities to do that.
So.
Uh, that's the thing.
India needs a thriving domestic industry of
design firms itself, which we do not have
right now.
So once we can get that up and running, then
it will be: Yeah, it will create a lot of
employment opportunities for engineers itself.
And if they end up actually building a fab,
that will actually give a lot of employment
to manufacturing laborers.
Right.
So probably we're going to see more investment
in training in the coming years and it might
not happen all of a sudden.
It'll take a lot of time, but there would
be more jobs, the way I understand it.
Thanks a lot.
It was very insightful.
It was "fab".
Thanks a lot for your time.
Thank you.
I think definitely the biggest takeaway for
me from that was how this is very much a marathon
and not a sprint.
And it's going to take so long to build up
that kind of expertise.
When you think of the decades that it's taken
Taiwan and I think it's really going to depend
now on where India decides to invest.
The opportunities are there.
We heard from Arjun whether it's opportunities
for engineers or even for manufacturing labor.
But the focus right now, it seems, or the
biggest potential, immediate, short-term potential
is design.
And it depends on how and to what extent India
really jumps on that now.
So it really depends where and to what extent
India decides to invest in these different
areas.
That's right.
And I think what I've really understood is
that multilateralism is the need of this industry.
So you would have one player who's good at
designing, like you just said; there's another
one who's actually got the raw material, yet
another one who can do the testing and manufacturing.
There would be someone else with the manpower,
but there can't be one player who can do everything.
So it has to be multilateral, and one can't
really strive to be self-sufficient.
That's my one takeaway.
And the other thing is when it comes to jobs,
which was our question in the beginning, that
jobs will be created, but probably in another
decade or so and not instantly.
Now we've understood the technicalities and
he being an electronic engineer, I think he's
really made us understand the technicalities
really well.
But let's try and figure out the politics
that's happening behind this whole technical
business.
For that, let's bring in our next guest.
So to understand the intricacies between India
and Taiwan relations, I'd like to bring in
Mr. Harsh V. Pant and he is the vice president
of Observer Research Foundation, ORF in New
Delhi.
Welcome to Global Eyes.
Now, Kate and I, we've been talking about
iPhone production, we've been talking about
semiconductors.
And we know that since this September, iPhones
and in fact, new iPhones are being made in
India.
I'd like to begin by asking you, how do you
really see this?
Is it safe to say that this is already part
of the shift away from dependency on China
centered supply chains?
I think it's the beginning of China plus one
track in some ways in supply chain diversification.
And we know that we live in an age where geo-economics
is being shaped by geopolitics and the sense
that you cannot be over dependent on any one
particular country.
And in particular China, I think, has changed
the dynamic of the supply chains: The way
we think about supply chains, the way we think
about restructuring them and balancing them.
And increasingly, there has been this idea
that India is perhaps one of the few countries,
that provides the economies of scale in ways
that few countries, few other countries do,
when you look at when you look at the shift
away from China.
So I think a lot of the companies are interested
in that, in looking at India through that,
through a newer lens.
And I think India also wants to be part of
a new story in global geo-economics, where
it presents itself as a credible production
house.
So a number of themes that India is interested
in, like strengthening its domestic manufacturing
base, providing alternative production linked
incentives to its own companies, as well as
welcoming foreign companies to come and invest
in India.
I think that has begun to take shape.
To what extent it goes forward, how extensive
and detailed that process is, that remains
to be seen.
But certainly I think we are beginning to
look at things in a different way.
And India remains at the heart of this new
supply chain restructuring.
So before we get into that a little bit more,
I just want to jump to one of your papers.
In the summer, you published an article in
Foreign Policy, where you wrote: "public enthusiasm
and semiconductors do not make a bilateral
relationship".
I'm just wondering if you could expand on
that a little bit more for us and explain
exactly what you meant by that.
I think what we meant by that is, look, there
is a there's a great degree of interest today
in Taiwan as far as India is concerned.
Indians have begun to look at Taiwan as a
nation that is very capable, that has done
a remarkable job when it comes to covert management
and is increasingly at the heart of contemporary
geo-technology and emerging technologies.
And I think that interest in itself is producing
a greater sense of anticipation about these
ties.
And on the other hand, you have this whole
debate about semiconductors and supply chain
restructuring, about semiconductors, and whether
semiconductor partnership between India and
Taiwan can be the nucleus of a broader partnership.
But what in fact, we were arguing in that
piece was, that India needs to look at Taiwan
more holistically.
Because Taiwan and what happens in and around
Taiwan in the coming years and decades will
also determine the future balance of power
in what we now call as the Indo-Pacific.
And unless India is more vocal, unless India
is more politically active in engaging with
Taiwan, I think there are going to be, you
know, this public enthusiasm and this newfound
interest in semiconductors will pay some dividends,
but not to the extent that perhaps many people
in India anticipate.
Now, I'd like to ask if India keeps getting
closer to Taiwan, the trade relations are
getting better and if I were to quote from
your paper, you've written that bilateral
trade with Taiwan stood at $5.7 billion in
2020, and it continues to grow.
And we're not only talking about private Taiwanese
companies who are trying to invest in India,
but it is also at the governments level that
both the countries, Taiwan and India, they're
trying to come closer.
I want to understand, can that be seen as
a deliberate attempt to irritate China?
Well, you know, there are two things.
One is, of course, India's relationship with
Taiwan, where trade and cultural ties have
long been part of India's engagement with
Taiwan.
India has a cultural centre, Indian trade
and cultural centre in Taiwan.
Taiwan has a similar centre in India.
Both countries interact at the level of educational
exchanges, people to people ties, trade and
commerce, as well as broader cultural interaction.
So there has been a sense that India needs
to cultivate and continue to engage Taiwan
as an entity, even in the context of one China
policy that India has articulated.
But at the other side of this is that in the
recent years, certainly many in India have
questioned India's continued adherence to
One China policy, when many in India believe
that China, in fact, never adheres to one
India policy.
And that has been a criticism that even Indian
policy makers have made openly that the relationship
between India and China has to be more reciprocal.
It cannot be a one-way street where India
continues to give in, whereas China continues
to demand more from India by unilaterally
changing the status quo along the border,
by challenging India across its periphery,
etc.
So I think that articulation that's a sense
that India needs to push back in certain ways
has also now given a new dynamic to India
-Taiwan relations.
Certainly India would like to increase the
engagement with Taiwan and Taiwan in particular
also is interested in increasing its engagement
with a country like India, because as I mentioned,
you know, apart from China, there are few
other countries apart from India that can
give Chinese industries, whether they are
semiconductor industry or the electronics
industry, the kind of economies of scale,
and that perhaps a big market like India or
a big country like India can provide.
I wonder, though, traditionally India has
always tried to keep equidistant in a way
between different powers, different blocs,
while still being able to be part of some
cooperative organization, so to speak.
So I'm wondering, how do you think these new
technological and economic ties between India
and Taiwan might affect this balancing act
of of Delhi's?
I think, you know, when it comes to China
today, there is there is no attempt to hide
India's frustration.
In New Delhi, policy makers are frustrated,
are anxious.
And I think ordinary people in India are also
very worried about Chinese behavior.
What happened in the Galwan Valley in in 2020,
where there was a major scuffle between the
two sides and soldiers on both sides died
first time in decades when there was violence
on the border has really shaken the Indian
perception of China.
In the past, also there were differences and
there was an acknowledgement of differences.
But the fact that we now have a very volatile
border with China where there is violence,
where there are deaths, where there is a sense
of apprehension of of what might come, that
has, I think, changed the nature of this relationship
fundamentally.
So I don't think there is any question that
India would not take those actions that are
needed to protect and preserve what India
believes are its core interests vis a vis
China.
And China has been also pushing India on a
number of fronts.
So what we have seen in the last few years
is India getting closer to like-minded countries
in the Indo-Pacific, whether it is the quadrilateral
security dialogue with the US, Australia,
Japan, whether it is conducting military exercises
with like-minded countries or whether it is
giving a signaling to China that it is willing
to engage Taiwan much more substantively than
before, if only to make a case to China that
India also has some cards on the table.
It is not as devoid of options in case China
becomes more aggressive or more assertive.
And in case China becomes more aggressive,
now, chances are that there could be armed
conflict in the Taiwan Strait.
So hypothetically talking, if that were to
happen, if China were to use military force
against Taiwan, how would India position itself?
Kate has just said she called it a balancing
act.
How would India balance itself in in the world
order?
I think a lot depends on China's behavior
over the coming years.
If China continues to be this assertive, this
aggressive, the kind of behavior that China
is pursuing vis a vis India today, if that
continues where China does not even acknowledge
Indian sensitivities, then I think India will
be more strident, both in the criticism of
Chinese behavior as well as in its support
for Taiwan.
The question is, you know, what other countries
are going to do, because India in and of itself
cannot change the dynamic vis a vis Taiwan
unless other countries, other democracies,
other like-minded entities in the region,
unless European Union, unless the US start
becoming more vocal about Taiwan, I don't
think India can change the fundamental reality
of Taiwan being, you know, a very small country
near a behemoth like China, and that will
have implications for Taiwanese future.
So I think a lot will depend on how the international
community, how the democratic world in particular
reacts to what happens in Taiwan Straits.
I mean, looking at the market right now, looking
at the supply chains right now, do you think
that EU will speak against China if, hypothetically
again, that situation were to arise?
Well, it's very unlikely and we have also
seen EU taking a very, very balancing attitude.
I think Kate used that word for India, but
I think it equally applies for Europe.
We have had German chancellor visiting China
despite criticism from some of Germany's closest
allies from within the government, etc.
So I think we know that there are divisions
within within European Union, within Europe
about the future of the relationship with
China.
And therefore, what I was saying was that
it would depend on what the Western world,
what the democratic world's reaction to what
happens in Taiwan is when there is a crisis.
The more united the democratic world is, the
better the chances are that one can provide
some support, some credible support to Taiwan.
But I think certainly given the dependencies,
given the supply chains at the moment and
given that strategic or economic decoupling
is really a long-term process, it would take
time.
And even India is aware of that.
India, for example, since 2020 has been trying
to make a case or has been trying to reduce
its dependence on China.
But it's very difficult.
India's trade with China is very high even
today, and it's trying to change that matrix,
but it's going to take a long time.
And I think the same would apply to Europe.
I just want to jump on a different point that
you mentioned there very briefly, which is
this economic decoupling, which makes me want
to get back actually to the geopolitics of
these semiconductors.
I mean, they're really seen as being so key
to the future in the coming decades, whether
it's through mastering emerging technologies
like AI and really, you know, they will play
such a key role in determining who really
has the upper hand in the 21st century.
You know, if you look back to the United States
just a couple of years ago, already in 2020,
the US imposed this embargo on the export
of American semiconductor technology to all
Chinese semiconductor firms.
We saw more restrictions and export controls
also related to semiconductors imposed just
a couple of months ago in October of this
year.
So I'm wondering effectively, this is, you
know, in this example, it's the US trying
to stop the flow of American technology to
China.
I'm wondering what is India's place in Washington's
plan right now?
Well, I think India is increasingly and of
course, as you mentioned, the emerging technologies
are at the heart of this geopolitical contestation
between US and China.
And US, as you mentioned, very rightly, has
been making a case not only within its in
its domestic legislation, but also to its
partners and allies that we need to relook
at our relationship with China when it comes
to emerging and strategic technologies.
And therefore, a lot of constraints are being
put into place, a lot of a framework is being
put in place that would make it virtually
impossible for China to leverage these kinds
of technological advantages from the US system.
Now, I think India, on the other hand, is
seen as a vital partner of the US and we have
seen India becoming a beneficiary of this
move away from China factor that that we are
witnessing.
Right.
So you've said a couple of times that you
cannot be dependent on any one country.
There's a need to reduce dependency.
And you just mentioned that India, US and
India, EU relationships will have to be worked
on.
Now I would like to wrap up with this that
recently Xi Jinping has said that in one of
his speeches that the country needs to become
self-reliant and China needs to strengthen
in the field of science and technology.
Now, that is also something that the Indian
Prime Minister likes to say a lot, that there
should be this Atmanirbhar Bharat self-reliant
India.
So when it comes to semiconductors, my question
is, is it even practically possible to be
self-reliant, to be completely independent
of others in this business?
I don't think so.
And I think that is why, you know, India,
for example, is so keen on Taiwan and a relationship
with Taiwan at this juncture, in particular
when it comes to semiconductor industry, because
certainly with all the emphasis on self-reliance
and Atmanirbhar Bharat, as you mentioned,
the idea actually has been that India's manufacturing
has been getting decimated over the last few
decades.
And this is the story of other major economic
powers as well, where we have seen China's
manufacturing capability growing, whereas
the manufacturing capacities of other countries
virtually almost disappearing.
And that has, I think, reignited this debate
as to how do we balance our economies better
so that the sustainability of our economic
engagement, the sort of lopsided economic
engagement that many countries have had with
China can be reduced.
And that is where this thing about self-reliance
comes from, because India, like many other
countries, wants to rebuild its manufacturing
base.
Now, in certain sectors, that's going to be
easy, in certain sectors, India has moved
ahead.
But in certain sectors, as you rightly mentioned,
like semiconductors, it's not possible to
do that, particularly in the short to medium
term.
And you have to create an entire ecosystem
that can generate the industrial infrastructure
for that.
And that's not going to happen overnight.
And therefore partnerships are going to be
important.
But partnerships again, would mean that how
do you define those partnerships?
Where do you go for those partnerships?
And I think most of the world is recognizing
the fact that instead of putting all your
eggs in one basket, it's better to diversify.
And in particular, you go to those countries
where you feel there is a greater degree of
trust and transparency.
I think, unfortunately, we're going to have
to wrap up there.
But thank you so much for your time and for
your insights.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
I think if one thing is clear, certainly partnerships
and diversifying are really the two key words
to take away from this right now as this economic
decoupling from China, not only by countries
like Germany and the US, but this is really
on a global scale and there's loads of huge
challenges there as well.
But of course, at the same time we have the
situation where you have these growing tensions
between China and Taiwan.
And as we heard from both of our really great
guests, we can see already how fragile the
supply chain is in creating these chips.
And so what a disturbance in the manufacturing
of these chips in Taiwan, for example, were
there to be any kind of Chinese aggression
towards Taiwan, what that would mean on a
global scale.
And it's really underlines, again, after what
we've already seen with the shortages at the
height of the pandemic, just what an integral
part of life and how our future really depends
on these chips, whether it's from everyday
electronics, from our phones to our toothbrushes,
even to advanced weapons.
So these chips and semiconductors really are
going to be so important in determining the
future of not only what we use every day around
the home, but also, you know, global politics
as well and our security.
Our future really depends on these chips,
that's correct.
And if I were to take the example of Russia,
since the war in Ukraine started, now America
has made sure that Russia does not get any
chips that has got anything to do with America,
whether it is design that was done in America
or whether the chips were produced there or
just about anything.
In India, you say, if I can again use a couple
of words in Hindi, in India they say "hukka
paani band karna".
Now that means when you have animosity with
someone, you make sure that they don't get
water, they don't get food.
But in this case, I understand when you have
to make sure that some economy should not
strive, then you're going to stop giving semiconductors
to them.
And another thing, one sentence that's going
to stay with me was what Harsh said, that
new partnerships, they're not going to happen
overnight.
So that is going to take time.
But whatever time it takes, whatever course
it takes, this is really going to decide our
future, semiconductor chips, the tiny, tiny,
tiny semiconductor chips.
Tiny thing, huge impact.
And it's going to be fab.
That's something I'm going to remember.
So what do you think?
What are you going to remember?
What did you learn out of this podcast?
Do let us know if you have any questions.
If you are watching us on YouTube, then please
leave a comment below and get in touch with
us.
Of course, if you have a question as well
on exactly how security policy is or could
affect your and our lives.
Then of course you can also let us know by
sending us an email to Globaleyes@dw.com.
We'd love to hear from you.
See you next time.
Goodbye.